how's everyone feeling tonight
right i mean we're about to give away
some amazing prizes
thank you guys for being here tonight
i'm just waiting for the binder and then
we will get started
but thank you each and every one of you
for being here i'm excited
to introduce some amazing people that
are come up and give you some amazing
prizes
so
your smile through your mask is making
me smile so thank you for smiling
so my name is adrian and i'm saying it
again shortly but i just want to make
sure to say hi
to everyone i want to get each one of
your names so i'm sure i'm going to get
it when you guys are getting your prizes
right
yeah because you guys are you're here
for something but you're not sure what
hmm i don't know either thank you
okay let's get this party started
so hello and welcome to the first of
eight
live winner announcement events for vax
days nevada a celebration of coven 19
vaccines and all the benefits they bring
i'm adrian i am your vax nevada days mc
and i am part of the vax nevada days
traveling prize patrol
for eight weeks starting today
vaccinated nevadans
will win a share of five million
in cash and prizes right
this insane
and each week we will visit the
hometowns of some of the biggest
winners to announce their vax invited
days prizes
live so if you see
our van pulling up into your town you
know some good things are coming
this is a statewide promotion and the
winners
can come from any corner of the state
that map right there can you guys see it
okay that map shows where
all of the 205 of this week's
winners live in addition to the prize
we'll be announcing tonight
there are also 125 nevada fishing
license winners
500 nevada state park annual entrance
permit winners
and 10 000 cash prize winners
can we get a hand whoa
okay so for today's live announcement
we are hosted by the college of southern
nevada
and it's so fitting right thank you
and it's so fitting to be here because
as nevada's vaccinated 12 to 14 year
olds
they're eligible to win 529
tuition prizes that will help pay for
higher education
including right here at csn
okay
so today is a celebration and
no one is more excited to reveal some
big winners
than nevada governor stephen
sisselak
governor thank you
thank you it is a real thrill to be here
today but it's going to be a bigger
thrill for you folks out there
and we're excited to be part of this
very very special day
thank you adrian i'm appreciate i'm
thrilled to be here with all of you
surrounded by
so many faces at sea smiling faces at
csn
and we're in the no better more fitting
place than the tyrone thompson student
union
who is i guarantee you smiling down
right now
at this event here today and at the
college this student union is named in
his honor
i miss his friendship every day and
grateful through this public health
measure we're going to help improve the
educational outcomes
for so many nevada students through
college savings plans
before we get to the big winners i know
you're anxious as am i
i want to provide an update on our
response to covet 19 in nevada
well we're in a much better place now
than we were a year ago
the pandemic is not over i'm going to
repeat that the pandemic is not over yet
we must do all we can to address
increased transmission
plateaued vaccination rates through an
all
all state government effort in
partnership with local leaders
since the announcement of our renewed
efforts we've already made significant
progress
fema has answered the call we'll have
boots on the ground here in nevada
southern nevada in particular next week
thanks to state agencies
immunized nevada community partners
southern nevada health district and
county leaders
we have 60 pop-up vaccination sites
6-0 pop-up vaccination sites scheduled
throughout clark county
this lottery is a shame
he has destroyed
[Music]
there's an individual that doesn't
understand that the vaccines are totally
safe they've been tested and we're
helping save lives which is what we're
doing
thank you i appreciate that
[Applause]
there's always going to be haters but no
one no state is more resilient than the
state of nevada
and we're going to do everything we can
to make sure that we vaccinate every
person
that wants the vaccine we're working
with southern nevada health district
and clark county to stand up more
long-term sites
with better hours and weekend
availability this effort includes
working with our state agencies
who have identified state buildings
throughout the valley that have the
potential
to serve as vaccination and testing
sites on a regular basis
finally csn has been hosting two testing
and vaccination sites at this campus and
their charleston campus
in partnership with the southern nevada
health district and the nevada national
guard
while they were scheduled to end these
sites mid-july
csn president dr sergosa
has graciously agreed to extend these
sites so they can remain open for our
communities
i am deeply appreciated dr sergosa
of your willingness to do that
[Applause]
in your institutions commitment to
keeping all of our
residents safe the state and our local
partners will continue to do everything
we can
to get every individual vaccinated and
we'll keep all of you updated
on our pr on our efforts but tonight
right now we got to celebrate one
incentive program
that gives nevadans 5 million more
reasons to get their shots
that's right five million more reasons
and we're starting giving away the money
and the prizes tonight
that's nevada days so let's get to it
i'll turn it back to adrian to introduce
our guests
who will be announcing our 529 college
savings plan winners
thank you appreciate it
[Applause]
thank you so much governor salac so to
announce today's
529 college saving plan winners
we have kirsten van rai chief of staff
of the state treasury office and dr
frederico
zargoza president of the college of
nevada
going up
a few of our lucky winners were able to
join us today and i'd like to invite
them
to come up on the stage now okay
our lucky winners for the announcement
come on up 529 winners
come on up kristen
all right well good evening everyone
thank you adrian and governor sislek
it's my honor to be here tonight on
behalf of state treasurer's at conine
he's
disappointed he wasn't able to join this
evening um as we announced some of the
young nevadans who have won 5 000
529 college savings plans so overall 10
lucky students between the ages of 12
and 17
have won the drawing to get five
thousand dollars in college savings
funds
and tonight i will be announcing five of
them and i have an envelope here with
five of the lucky winners
and the winners are madeline s from
carson city
mariano g from lovelock zarin
you from reno alexander s from las vegas
and with us here today zachary from las
vegas come on over and get your check
so thank you and congratulations to
zachary and all of our five thousand
dollar tuition prize winners
dr z will now join us to announce three
twenty thousand dollar scholarship
winner
thank you you take that home put on your
wall yeah
thank you kristen what an amazing day
for all the winners
and i'm so glad to see us that was able
to host this amazing event
here at the tyrone thompson student
union center here at the north vegas
campus
so i can't wait
i i really can't wait to see some of
these students come to
come through the gates and doors of
higher education institutions throughout
southern nevada
throughout the state of nevada
especially here at the college southern
nevada
so overall we have three lucky students
winning twenty thousand dollar
college saving plans and we're gonna
announce them i'm excited to announce
uh one of the winners who happens to be
here today
and i don't believe the individual knows
who that winner is
so without further ado could i
ask the mean from las vegas to come
damien from las vegas to come on up
damien congratulations thank you
congratulations man big winner
20 000 whoa let's get those sides yeah
[Applause]
daniel which are you
congratulations
thank you uh dr z a college savings plan
that will cover fifty thousand five zero
fifty thousand dollars in tuition will
make a truly
life-changing impact for the next
individual
this 529 plan will enable a young
nevadan
to pursue their higher education goals
and be prepared for the workforce upon
completion of their degree
i'm delighted to announce the winner of
the 50 000
college savings prize in the first vax
nevada days drawing
i feel like we're at the oscars here or
something i got the envelope please
kiana b from las vegas
[Applause]
congratulations
[Music]
got her vax band-aid on here folks
[Applause]
and now i'm going to give it back to
adriana
oh my gosh
i don't know about you but my heart is
really racing for every announcement i
mean i've got tears in my eyes at this
point
congratulations to all of the young 529
tuition savings plan winners
okay now to today's cash
winners to help with the announcement
we have congressman steve houseford
who has joined us but first we're going
to have heidi parker from immunize
nevada
come up to give us a quick introduction
about
our thousand dollar cash winner
thank you everyone for joining us
tonight and i just want to thank
governor sislek again for
all he's done not only to help us launch
facts nevada days
but also just lifting up vaccinations in
our state and really supporting the
effort
all across the state we couldn't do it
without you in your office so thank you
so we have 10 lucky thousand dollar
winners tonight
and one of our winners is jessie and
elko so
shout out for jesse and elko but we also
have diego from las vegas
he was going to try to join us tonight
i'm not sure if he made it
but just wanted to say thank you to all
of our thousand dollar winners thanks
for getting vaccinated
and now i will turn it over to
congressman horseford
well hello and thank you adrian and to
governor sisselak for your tremendous
leadership
to the first lady and to everyone dr z
and the entire college of southern
nevada
north las vegas campus thank you to
everyone who is watching
both here and online as we celebrate the
benefits
of vaccination and give away some
amazing prizes
i'm i'm so excited to be here in the
heart of congressional district four
for this announcement and as the
governor mentioned
it's an honor to be here in a building
named after the late assemblyman tyrone
thompson a true
champion of education and i am
honored to be with all of you uh for
this backs
nevada days uh cash drawing as a
reminder
to be eligible for the bach's nevada
days cash drawing
you simply need to be a nevadan over 18
who has been vaccinated against cobit 19
overall uh four lucky nevadans
won a 25 000 prize this week tonight
i get to announce two of those
winners
25 dollars it pays to vaccinate
and the winners are laurie b
from washoe valley and
juan l from las vegas with us here
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
taiwan congratulations
congratulations juan and thank you for
getting
vaccinated to protect yourselves your
family and our community
and it's my pleasure to turn it back to
governor sisilak to announce
our final big cash winners this week
let's get out there and continue to get
vaccinated nevada
thank you congressman horsford we
appreciate all that you're doing and the
great job you're doing representing
the state of nevada before we announce
our big cash winners this is a reminder
every one of you every person is a
winner
if they get vaccinated it is saving
lives it is preventing hospitalizations
it is protecting your family and your
friends
and we appreciate it we encourage
everyone who's not gotten vaccinated
go and get the vaccination if you've
gotten the first one go and get the
second one
it doubles your chances of winning next
week so we hope that you take advantage
of that as soon as you can
we have two remaining winners who have
joined us tonight one is here and one is
not here
and i think they're excited to hear what
they've won so if you want to please
join me on stage
i will be announcing the winner of the
50 000
cash prize and the winner of the
quarter of a million dollar cash prize
quarter of a million the winner
of the 50 000 cash prize is
jared from las vegas which means
elizabeth
from north las vegas has just won a
quarter of a million dollars
a quarter of a million dollars
[Music]
her husband has no idea until you guys
broadcast this and she just wanted a
quarter of a million dollars
you okay
she's getting more reaction from this
than from the shot the shot was painless
the shot was totally painless
congratulations that's right
[Applause]
close my books so i got to get back to
the right page
uh before we finish i want to say just a
few words about elizabeth
our quarter of a million men quarter of
a million dollar catchphrase
she can't catch your breath up here
she's having trouble breathing
uh elizabeth is a kindergarten teacher
from right here from right here in north
las vegas
when my immunization team phoned
elizabeth
she mentioned that she was happy to be
vaccinated so she could be back in the
classroom with her students
she said she'd be happy to win any prize
amount saying that any amount
would help her get supplies for her
students in her classrooms
well i hope you're not going to spend
the whole 250 000
supplies elizabeth 250
000 is a lot of money and i know your
students are cheering at home right now
as they're watching television we're so
delighted to award you this prize
and thank you for winning but thank you
for getting your vaccine
now i'll turn it back to adrian to close
us out thank you all so much for joining
us
thank you oh my goodness
wow well what an exciting day for these
lucky vaccinated nevadans to be entered
in the rest of the vax nevada day
drawings just get your coven 19 vaccine
you'll get protection from the kovi 19
virus and a shot at some incredible
prizes
are you already vaccinated like me well
you're automatically entered so find all
the details
at vaxnervatidays.org and tune in
next thursday as we reveal more big
winners live
thank you guys for coming thank you have
a great night
congratulations to all the winners